hey what's up it's your girl gloria aka
big glow and i'm chilling it on the
bootleg kill 5k let go
all right look it's the bullet cap show
we have a special guest in here
very excited to be talking with this
young lady
gloria hey what the [ __ ] is up i can
curse you yeah i mean listen you're
smoking drugs we're smoking drugs
together all right this be the only
radio interview where this is happening
that you probably do yeah because
everybody else is like you know you got
to go to the iheart building you got to
go to the um i think actually on what um
baby jay know
they they be smoking in there
shout out to them what station is that
shout them out
big fix oh big facts pogba yeah that's a
podcast
shout out to them shout out to the big
fats podcast great podcast shout out my
guy uh
the whole crew over there is fire um so
you have the [ __ ] hottest record in
the [ __ ] country
how's that feel
yeah amazing
feels good great yeah how long i know
this song has been out for a while how
long was the song out before like it
really like did like you noticed like
[ __ ] like really start to go viral it
got vowel before i put slung out
was it because of the uh ig clip of the
video
well before the um the video clip i had
did like a little trillion to it
and i was just dancing this junk got the
gun varying that what made us want to go
and put it out
and so when we did the video and
we did the video we shot the video and
we had the video back the next day so
less than 24 hours when i put a clip of
that out you got to go on barrel
soon as i posted it then
when we actually dropped the song
it was over yeah and the video was just
a classic video i had so many people
hitting me like oh you see this yo you
see this it's just crazy yeah
is everyone in that video like you're
you're close home girls yeah those are
your folks yeah i am yeah everybody
video
[Music]
folks um what part are you from memphis
right yeah what part of memphis you're
from our age of louisiana
we are the west side phrase do you
remember frasier boy from uh hypnotized
minds click back in the day yeah frasier
boy was like a memphis legend you know
yeah shout out to him um
memphis i feel like it's very much like
in the forefront of hip-hop the last
like three or four years yeah it's like
right now it's like memphis and detroit
both on fire yep
what do you think it is about memphis
that's been so influential to the game
the last few years we got like a
different sound we got our own sound
that don't nobody else get
like don't nobody else like you when you
see a memphis person you know that from
memphis and y'all say music
[Music]
every time i hang out with money bag
yellow or somebody they're always like
music and i'm like bro
i i never knew that we said it the same
type of way until i started seeing can
you say it
where is it see there it is
i said it right daytime no you said it
like someone from memphis would say it
i i ain't saying normal time you said
merger i tried to say right no it's all
good that's where you're from look it's
all crazy though cause like like i said
like i ain't know there was like people
and i know that was like something we
only said until other people started
saying why y'all say it like that
not to get into the details of the whole
situation but
i was talking to saucy santana great guy
yeah we had a very fun conversation
uh and we were talking about how
this canceled culture [ __ ] when you
start to start to get like a certain
amount of like momentum it always feels
like people are trying to bring you down
you had something similar happened to
you recently when people try to bring up
old tweets
is that frustrating where you're like
catching a wave and you know you have
big moments in your career start to
happen and then
it feels like the internet's always
trying to bring a [ __ ] down
it's like um that be making up stuff
yeah so some of the stuff that was
brought back up was not even real
yeah like i don't even know what people
talking about maybe bringing up to me
i'm like what you talking about right do
you feel like um
in general like once you start like now
that you're experiencing all the success
do you feel like
you're feeling the hate as well like at
a all-time high at the same time i feel
like everybody that just come out though
um
go and get the hate because like you
knew you know i'm saying they got to say
something bad about you because like
everything going good somebody
can't everybody can't love you
especially like if you're going to the
top everybody's not going to lose you
most people don't know you but you got
to be a couple people
don't like the fact that you're going up
so that you gotta hate but it won't be
right if they can do that though yeah
you have this song is so crazy uh being
from memphis there's some legendary
female rappers from memphis
uh shout out to gangster boo the chat uh
any influence from them growing up yeah
like they got the
you know what i'm saying
gangsta
i feel like memphis uh created the
gangster movies
so yeah like they brought they really
put that gangster in the industry a lot
like la2 like l.a memphis
like
but like i ain't never knew no uh like
who back in the day from l.a female
rapper lady of rage um
well [ __ ] rage is from virginia
she was on doggy style though
yeah so like me if he's feeling he
corrupts from philly technically then
you know but yeah no i would just say
though i mean yeah gangster boo was
[ __ ] she was i mean she's
still that [ __ ] but like you know i
mean she had a crazy run yeah yeah i
feel like she influenced a lot of
what was going on too i feel like three
six mafia in general yeah they they i
feel like they had the biggest one
something like one of the biggest
impacts on music yeah because they had
like i feel like what they were doing
with like the chants and [ __ ]
kind of like got popularized
commercially by little john even though
they did it first does that make sense
like little john was like b.i.b.i and
then like you know 360 mafia was like
tear the club up but they were doing
that [ __ ] first
i don't know i don't know they never get
enough credit i don't feel like yeah
like a lot of times they i feel like
maybe they don't get as much credit as
they deserve it's coming around though
mo definitely just starting to come
around 100
um what uh for you obviously you know
cmg is
i feel like the last time we saw a
similar run for like a hip-hop label
was probably in like 2010 or 11 with mmg
um shout out to ross but the cmg run is
crazy right now the roster is stacked we
see omg champions it's like the warriors
in 2017. it's crazy it's like
it uh was it just a no-brainer to [ __ ]
with with gotti because obviously he's a
stand-up guy and
i mean [ __ ] he's got a real ear for
talent and he's from your city
yeah like
it was
i was like when everybody else leave me
i was you know i'm saying excited
because like at first the when
on the left see me
now they're going crazy to hit me up
and so like you know i'm just going to
jump but it was like different when god
had called me because it like
i used to like always back and they sent
my music to him
when i was just just coming up yeah
wanting him to be one of the people that
heard it so when he he reached out to me
like he reached out to me quick to
deal crazy i was like so back in the day
you were sending him your [ __ ] before
you were even
yeah like i used to send my movie to
like um people like
gotti uh
you know nicki
carter like people who i feel like who i
listen to you know i'm saying growing up
i just used
okay maybe at least two did you ever
send a song to zach randolph when he was
playing for the grizzlies because i
heard you know he he was signing fools
out there
big zebo yeah he's so crazy i never
thought about doing it
i know i think he found money boy he
didn't find money back yo but i know you
know money bag came up with it through
his [ __ ] so yeah for sure but it was so
crazy like
i knew
zach randolph of course but i didn't
memphis
they do so like when uh the
when they were doing english i used to
always hear them say zebo i i really
didn't know that was sex oh you didn't
put two and two together no yeah i
didn't know until like i started scene
i'm like ow
like do new zagret though what up we
gotta interrupt the interview real quick
to tell you about our people at bluechu
don't forget to go to bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg right now and
get your first month free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars in shipping it's
the uh man fellas the game changer
that's all i'm gonna say you pop the
blue chew and your dick is on a million
man i'm not saying it makes it bigger
but it feels bigger i'm just saying i'm
not saying but i'm saying uh look same
active ingredient asialis and viagra
minus the awkward visits to the doctor's
office all right it's all over the phone
it's so easy they ship it right to your
door in discrete packaging i don't know
if you're going through erectile
dysfunction because you're stressed out
at work uh maybe uh you just need a
little extra hump with wifey whatever it
is maybe you just want to take a
bluetooth and beat your dick like it
stole something just to feel like
damn that shit's hard bruh you know what
i'm saying go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg right now and you
will save uh all money it's free yeah
you'll you'll get a whole month for free
bluechew.com promo code bootleg for a
whole month for free delivered to your
door discreetly no doctor's appointments
no awkward visits same viagra cialis
ingredients
man what are you waiting for go do that
as you were mentioned uh nikki earlier
and cardi has uh
any of the
ogs
reached out given you props showed you
some love maybe slid you in the dm like
you know obviously
um uh cardi she showed me love she she
be saying she bring me up in her
interviews
um
i saw nikki had a show i think that new
orleans
she had a played if and if during her to
break what they what they got him
yeah yeah she played the
damn um every time i win me or everybody
[ __ ] everybody just
spread the love to everybody the most
fun they shot me was when shake because
i didn't know shaq was into music mm-hmm
then he used to rap i didn't know this
he actually might be the best basketball
player rapper of all time he he has a
song with nas and jay-z at the same time
yes damn i ain't noticed but
yeah he was one of the first people i'm
like damn shaq see me and i love [ __ ]
[ __ ] who doesn't love shaq he might be
the most lovable human being ever yeah
like i loved him growing up like when i
was younger i was elected seeing him and
kobe my favorite two people you're a
lakerson yeah i'm like the same for sure
why yeah you're from memphis you guys
have the grizzlies but i like the lakers
you guys had uh i don't got no teams
mike conley junior in
yeah like i like the group
because that's where i'm from but the
lagos was my team and like my favorite
because like growing up you loved kobe
i love kobe so was kobe like the reason
you [ __ ] with the lakers or was it
shocking they were both
like i just like i don't even remember
how i picked the lakers to be my team
they were good i just remember watching
them and knowing that on my team if it
was that era i'm not sure that grizzlies
were even in memphis yet they still
might have been in vancouver so maybe
you started [ __ ] with them before you
all had a team
i don't even remember i remember i was
young and i lost you a pretty big pretty
big basketball fan
i like
i used to like
watching basketball
but i never liked 2k games i like
football playing the game boys i play
madden i love man this is my favorite
game like i will put the ass on there
word hat like what's your go-to team if
we were to play that's my team the
steelers
what is going on i love the stillers yes
so my football team is the steelers in
my basketball team mr lakers i got
college football and basketball teams
too when's the last time you played with
the steelers
like when's the last time you played a
game of madden with the steelers because
i'm trying to figure out which
quarterback you were using because it's
been dark recently i ain't never used
quarterback later than big beans it's
probably it was big ben yeah but was it
like big ben like 2021 big ben because
that's like a 78 overall you know what i
mean
yeah i'll play with him yeah but then i
played the game last year when my cousin
i was at his ass and i he cooked some
mexican pizzas for them kataka bill and
selling them and so they had man over
there i'm like they're like what's wrong
they put it on i'm like oh whoop one of
you out here because i know i love that
game and we end up playing and i was
winning because i'm cold i love the
bedroom check you out
let's not pass over the mexican pizza
you made a mexican pizza
hey it was good
cause i think i got a picture in my
phone
let's let's see this photo if you have
it because i was very sad
when taco bell canceled the mexican
pizza
it was gone for about a year but they
just announced they're bringing it back
permanently you might have had something
to do with this yeah i used to make post
about it then let me say this so i
forgot one thing and it was the sauce
and by the time i forget it the stuff
was closed
you might look a little dry but it was
still good like you could ask everybody
i cooked for like they were like damn
but no salsa
it was some sauce on it but like it won
a lot of sauce didn't i even tell them
to go to taco bell to get some sauce
that's what you need to do you got to
get the actual sauce from taco bell yeah
but they were closed like i went over
there
and cooked this sounds like the most
munchies ass [ __ ] night of your life
it was like everything's closed it's 3
30 in the morning i'm making mexican
pizzas for everybody nah cause the whole
day you were playing it's like i just
pulled up over there ladies here like i
said with them like i want to make a
biscuit
i want to make a mexican pizza [ __ ]
in memphis too they there's no way
there's good mexican food in memphis
it's great barbecue but is there good
mexican food
yeah
how good though like we're in l.a this
is the [ __ ] epicenter of the well see
that ain't [ __ ] with you like she but
like we got like a lot of mexican
restaurants like
because you know happy mexican
you never heard of happy meals happy
mexican that's my wife
she's a happy mexican oh damn i thought
you would talk about the food no my wife
is mexican i like that i think she's
happy
[Music]
[Laughter]
but yeah like she might be the
indifferent mexican
you mean if it's anybody oh here we go
and memphis everybody go to uh
mexican restaurants to get drunk so it's
a lot of it's a good place to get drunk
okay guys let's see if we can get we're
gonna look at that one
[Laughter]
oh wait there's a lady with a baby
that's my best friend let me try to go
through a picture i hope he didn't just
show her tits on accident
hold on a minute
she
i don't know i know she
see you under the cover let me crappy
real quick
it looks good it looks good not bad okay
okay
okay yeah
so i'm just gonna pause it right there
just show that yeah show that camera
there you go beautiful
your battery's here it was good
it looks good looks like a mexican pizza
from taco bell i gotta ask you a
question though
would you consider yourself a good cook
i can what i know how to cook i cook
excuse me what do you know how to cook
besides my fish and spaghetti like i
make the best spaghetti in the real life
at the same time not together right
separate separate oh my god see you
ain't for me that what we doing if you
like we do fishing spaghetti
all at once that's the best combination
in the world spaghetti like i swear to
god i'll be out i'd be like i want some
fish and spaghetti so you put like a
tilapia on top of your spaghetti not
together like that's what i was i don't
know fish then on the side spaghetti
that's like chicken alfredo what
[Laughter]
y'all know about pizza spaghetti though
that sounds like okay
hey do you think memphis has the best
barbecue in the world because they
always say it's like memphis or kansas
or texas if it's for sure
yeah if i really don't deal with me
phenomenal barbecue what's like your if
i were to go there to visit what would
be the singular barbecue spot i would
have to the giant i like is in actually
it ain't even in memphis it's in south
haven it's called memphis barbecue
you know south haven in mississippi but
it's like it's in mississippi yeah but
it's like right there about me if it's
like me if it's
right there once you cross a red light
they got casinos in mississippi right
do you like is that do that do you ever
just go party in mississippi
go hit the casino no
like uh
my so i gotta associate to stay in south
haven that's the only time i used to go
out there then like
actually i was just living in my
friend's house she like stay like he's
about like it's called
what it's called what's what where's who
is right bad mississippi so like okay
instead of going to the stoves in which
we
drive like if they look 15 20 minutes
you got me sippy that's how close me
sipping me if you see us hmm
super close
when i grew up i just thought
mississippi was like just everybody was
in the kkk because every
every racist movie that's ever existed
in the 90s was in mississippi there's
mississippi burning
what was the one where samuel jackson
killed the [ __ ] uh
matthew time to kill mississippi for
sure
yeah we can't say
i've watched enough
[ __ ] matthew mcconaughey movies to
know
to the casino one time and that was when
i turned
21. no i was already 21 actually
it was before i turned 22 and i just
went because i had got some money did
you win money no i lost two hundred
dollars in stock
i hate losing money like i could never
be a casino person oh yeah it gets it
gets really dark i once lost 21 thousand
dollars in a weekend
yeah you want to see not bad no i was
just bored at home betting on sports you
like [ __ ] let me lose some money
betting on sports in the middle of a
pandemic
shout out to the goddamn jets for
beating the bengals
mike white you remember that game third
stringer
what's your football team whoever i'm
betting on
got one i'm a cardinals fan i'm from
arizona we whooped yeah
who's we again what are the steelers oh
yeah in the super bowl yeah we whooped
our ladies in the super bowl with
antonio holmes
touchdown
and he was out of bounds give me that
when he was out
he got that touchdown and won the game
yeah who's out of bounds yeah shout out
to antonio holmes yeah
shout out to big ben
quite possibly the creepiest guy to play
in the nfl not named desean watson
hey don't play with me
no no he's cool he just he just you know
he he just you know i'm he's just he's
gonna do no wrong he's aggressive he can
do not wrong he's an aggressive guy
what if he don't i mean you know he's
been accused of being a little a little
aggressive
[Laughter]
i should say that people who don't like
him call him bed rapeless brother
wow that's that's his nickname amongst
non-stealer fans yeah damn
playing him because wow well he retired
it's over
he didn't know i'm saying you've been
watching football
quarterback's gonna be either mitch
trubisky mason rudolph
or kenny pickett so good luck
hey i don't know none of those guys
they're all bugs
that's all you need to know you guys you
guys got naji harris and a bunch of
[ __ ] wow well on defense you guys i
really feel bad like i'm not
representing wheel right now
and you also have an oakland ace hat on
your team [ __ ] is all over the map
what do i hear do i have them it looks
like an oakland a's hat i don't know i
just put it on because it matched my
outfit i respect it but yeah like i
really who is who do we have
naji harris
t.j watt
who do we have david we need
the tick-tocking guy left
uh the guy who was overrated as [ __ ]
with his name
oh that was a long time ago yeah so i
ain't talking about that
would you do a song with antonio brown
just because he was like a legendary
steeler that's my then my boy that my
[ __ ] like i just saw him he was dancing
and he was like oh god happened to y'all
make some little
what if he sent you a song it was just
god-awful
antonio brown shoots you a record you
listen to and you're like jesus christ
what is happening
because i've heard some of his songs and
i said that to myself out loud
like who the what the [ __ ] is going on
here why is rolling out booking this
[ __ ] man this
bad boy is my favorite [ __ ] interview
why is it so funny is it is it the wii
i don't know but antonio brown sent you
a song it's a steaming pile of dog [ __ ]
but he's a b he's got he's got ben
roethlisberger doing the [ __ ] intro
of the record talking his ditty [ __ ]
rosters like yeah i did it [ __ ]
no charges no charges uh
would you do the record
what'd you do the record
ain't nobody
i don't omaha clean the book
she's like
what
what
big ben's talking diddy [ __ ] i'm on
there
[ __ ] it
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our partners our
family at odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com right now
and the promo code bootleg kev it'll get
you 20 off the fly of socks in the world
[ __ ] spongebob
[ __ ] cheez-its
a little bit of pepsi
uh how about how about some underwear do
we like underwear e.t boxers let's go
ahead and just open up a pair of these
boys
so you can see how fly the draws are
ladies and gentlemen because they are
fly by the way they just gave me my own
pair of odd socks go on my social media
and you could see them uh i don't know
if they're going to be for sale
because let's be honest
who wants to wear socks with my [ __ ]
ugly face on them besides my wife and
she don't even want to wear them there
we go
they got the draws they got it all man
get the odd socks basics which i love
just the basic boys these are amazing
comfy socks on socksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off let's
get back to the interview yeah it's like
antonio brown and big being like
they like
okay so let me tell you this how like
people what's uh heinz ward is the guy
though let's shout out to him y'all got
a ring behind hans wood love trump
are you a real football player or a
football fan
football player you're a real football
fan
who is um back in the day you guys had a
[ __ ] i mean you pretty much was it
paula malu what was the other guy the
tight end white dude i used to have a
fan
yeah heath miller mm-hmm
oh yeah you're a [ __ ]
you ain't playing with your football
[ __ ]
he's somebody i'm missing he played
defense
you wanna handle it
how how long back
oh uh hey james harrison yes
and how about somebody embarrassing too
james harrison was a [ __ ] monster
yeah
that's what [ __ ] the cardinals was
that's pick six he had at halftime in
that game and he returned it for a
touchdown that [ __ ]
jesus christ oh yeah antonio was my
favorite one because like he the only
super bowl that i saw get one since i
was the last so i had to respect antonio
holmes you didn't see them beat the uh
was it the seahawks and like
i just started becoming a football
player all right playing fantastic 2003
at least you got to win is your team
with a super bowl right none of my
team's won [ __ ]
i thought you didn't have a team no i
okay i'm a cardinal fan i'm a phoenix
sons fan so my the sons haven't won [ __ ]
and the cardinals
haven't won [ __ ]
they got nothing
the cardinals don't got [ __ ] of a super
bowl what do you mean they they went to
one and we lost
do you [ __ ] guys what's what happened
when y'all
yeah for a second and then we [ __ ]
lost in a close game yes cause he got
that in the last couple seconds i was
like i broke my heart i would rather
have gotten blown out
pause yeah
yeah
cause you had a lot of hope
i feel so bad
thank you for that
you're so nice um are you like now that
you uh obviously are in a different
place financially successful wise all
that good [ __ ]
could somebody like let's say you pull
up to [ __ ]
dayton ohio to do a show right yeah and
like the local rapper in the city's got
like a [ __ ] 30 pack 30 bands for you
in a bag just will you hop on the record
or are you trying to protect the brand
and kind of minimize that yeah that's
what i'm on like at this point like
you know i this one thing i will do like
i would support but
if i support it's going to be memphis
rappers they're like i'll do a song who
you're not worrying about
you know i'm saying like protecting the
ram but like now like i gotta like make
you know what i'm saying i can't just be
doing features this can't be helping
everybody out yeah like i gotta make
sure i gotta you know what i'm saying no
yeah you gotta contact me you gotta
because once you get going it's like
you're gonna be able to
really get it like per person get a
crazy crazy situation how's your album
coming along
working on it right now is we speak
would you give me a percentage
audi
40.
yeah he's approaching halfway point
there
i want to say 60 but i'm like nah let me
take it back because i'm still deciding
if i want to keep certain songs
of course
are you uh any any features locked in
yet
there's tons of them you you got them
all we'll see i'm sure i got i got some
features on there yeah not a lot though
is it safe to
say somebody from the camp is on your
album
yeah
is it safe to say his name's
money baguio
safe to say i don't know music
oh hey you said you love matthew
mcconaughey are you like a movie buff
too you're a football buff are you in
the movies like you pretty big uh
growing up i uh loved movies but like
now i don't watch tv i it's been like
years since like i really don't watch tv
like i watch sometimes like reality
shows like i'll be watching bad girls
club and now where do you even watch
that [ __ ] like the zeus club whatever
zeus channel [ __ ] what is that a [ __ ]
yeah i just know every blog like
hollywood like every other week this is
like just people beating the [ __ ] out of
each other outside
yeah like i liked it and i like like
jasmine's cowboy that's the only dress i
watched it on my phone though but i
really don't watch tv but back then i
used to love movies and tv shows isn't
uh blueface's girlfriend who's insane
with no teeth isn't she on one of those
shows
yeah baby chris shawn sean what's her
name christina rat yeah shout out to her
she's have you ever seen anybody it's
crazy for like you've got a homegirl
like that that was just like dick crazy
like for sean roberts
i'm about to say you know i actually
know somebody who was worse than her
really totally me
but
it was you
[Laughter]
you're telling me you're worse than
krishan rock at a point in time in your
life
you know i feel like she kind of normal
besides the tattoos she you think she's
normal yay really yeah
you know that
she broke into his house
cut herself open
drew a love letter to him in blood and
then stole his g wagon and drove it
across the country and was found in like
kentucky like three days later you
really just made that oh my god
google that [ __ ] i swear
i didn't make that up that happened and
he looked so seriously
i swear i didn't make it up
i didn't make it up you got to see this
it's listen okay
rock
[Music]
car i'm just gonna type it blood
sounds like a [ __ ] great album
all right uh blue face began and around
okay here we go
blue face knows his former artist chris
shawn rock stole his car and he's
sharing all the evidence to prove it in
a lengthy series of instagram story
posts on tuesday blueface began to
unravel an array of text messages
between him before she reportedly stole
his g-wagon
she wrote i love blue in blood and then
stole his [ __ ] car
that was quite normal to me i was gonna
say
tell me about the time you went to jail
for a boyfriend because apparently you
[ __ ] you're turnt up oh no so what
was what's the craziest thing you've
done because this girl beat the [ __ ] at
him on camera
so what have you done
have you ever have you ever chopped up
clothes yes that's happened to me yeah i
did it twice
damn but you know i had to stop because
i'm like okay i don't want nobody [ __ ]
with my [ __ ] right but um
i tried to kill him
i tried to like
make my gun go blogger blogger
well i uh
you try to kill it what did he cheat on
you
okay so like
the first time no this all happened at
once so bam i went to the club he wasn't
texting me back you know he had the
occasional song oh so you had his
location so you know yeah
and so i wasn't there trying to fight
but then
he was getting buried so he would like
go to the back so he went to the back
and so i
did that he hit my head back i'm like
[ __ ] so oh he hit you back yeah yeah he
never human being so
i went to my i said i went my gun i went
in my pocket like i know i'm gonna have
my gun in my purse she's just by the way
you got into the club with a gun no
problem yeah it's clean
okay okay
so yeah i know i'm gonna have my gun in
my purse and he noted but i actually
didn't walk in the club my first because
i didn't want nobody to notice me
because i walked in the club with all
black on like oh he was uh he was on a
mission you were straight
yes i'll put the gun in my hoodie in the
front jesus so he didn't know i had it
so that's why he hit me because he did
he knew i i should she had that so he
did that i might he kind of came off a
little bit so i went in my pocket
instead i went in my pocket he saw that
it was like damn
he ran so [ __ ]
he ran fast [ __ ] then ran around all
his friends so they were like well i'm
glad that that didn't happen you know
yeah but look i was trying that like i
was cool the next day like i was like
like i wasn't mad no more but i was
telling my friend i'm like soon as he
comes i'm had a pillow right here
and i'm just gonna shoot him
well [ __ ] he knew that i was gonna do
that like he was like no are you guys uh
did you guys like end up staying
together after this
or was that like the last straw or did
you guys keep it going for a little
longer
yeah it was the last straw for like
three days and then it was back run it
back where's he at now
i think he died
[ __ ]
did you you didn't kill him obviously
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
are your dms pretty flooded nowadays
like when it comes to just random dudes
just like you know doing the thing that
we perceive females to be the only
people that do but guys are bigger
creeps i feel like
like do you ever get the random dick pic
in the dna
like damn strangers dicks are just
flying at me like that one dude on
instagram they do it on snapchat they
got it real in facebook too but facebook
they gotta realize senior citizens are
sending you dick pics on facebook like
different people
what's going on
imagine hitting on somebody on facebook
where it's your government name and all
your friends and family are on there
what there's nothing discreet about that
i get the snapchat you just make up a
little [ __ ] username and you start
sending dick pics flying
hoping somebody hits back you know
i've ever been to a public place and
someone's just sent you an unsolicited
airdrop photo
nah like i was in line at [ __ ]
disneyland
and this [ __ ] just kept sending
me [ __ ] pictures of dicks
[Laughter]
it was like a variation of dicks and i
had to i and i just i just switched from
android to iphone so i don't know how to
turn the [ __ ] off
it's like somebody clearly in line doing
this to everybody you know
i'm just dick pic dick pic oh there's a
brown one there's a white one there's a
pink one
[Music]
it was it was a good prank if i was if i
was like 14 with an iphone backing that
i would have been doing all kinds of
wild [ __ ] like
we used to egg people
for you you'd be driving down the road
people would be walking down the street
you throw an egg at him
yeah you're a bad girl that one we ate
prostitutes once in a pimp almost killed
us when i was like 14. you do it there's
a street in phoenix arizona called van
buren it was the track where all the
[ __ ] would walk when they were
selling their vagina before only fans
before backpage even shout out to
backpage what happened to y'all anyway
i think we're both high but yeah so this
is the street where all the hookers
would be [ __ ] back and forth back and
forth back and forth
this is like you know when uh
prostitutes who walked the street were
actually attractive not you know
crackheads um but we used to on like
back then the prostitutes
yeah i mean when they were walking the
street nowadays if a chick is walking
the street [ __ ] you don't got internet
what are you doing
why are you out here
go in the [ __ ] hotel put an ad a
[ __ ] and relax
jesus
[Laughter]
anyway so we used to
fill up uh water balloons and buy
cartons of eggs and we had hit we'd toss
eggs at prostitutes
and then a pimp chased us once
but we used to just toss a like hip hit
he was in the car and he got in the car
and chased down no no he like like he
pulled off and like was like a [ __ ]
crazy ass [ __ ] escalade chasing us
for like six lights
yeah it was pretty crazy where i was 14
and my best friend was like 15 we stole
our parents car and we just would go
[ __ ] do all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
this is when jackass was popping you
remember jackass right um so we used to
jackass dumb [ __ ]
push ourselves like in shopping carts
over curbs
some real white trash ash white people
[ __ ] for sure
even though the person pushing the car
was not white he was black shout out to
my best friend ramses
do you have any like uh like like any
immediate
just white [ __ ] in your circle
that always are doing white people [ __ ]
like ordering bologna sandwiches yeah
totally
totally good yeah totally
[Laughter]
well listen the album is 40 done yeah
it's coming soon
uh are you do you feel any pressure
following up
fnf
nah
cause like people been liking my little
movies i've been putting out good [ __ ]
that's all that matters yeah 100 so
album coming soon
uh are you going to be hopping on
anybody else's record soon um
yeah
maybe
maybe not
maybe maybe not well this was fun
yeah my definitely who liked that
podcast boom
that was [ __ ] great
yeah my dad
real quick can i get you to just look at
this camera
okay
you rolling